[Musique]
la saison des litchis à la réunion est
un grand moment il s'agit de l'un des
fruits les plus attendus souvent
indissociables des fêtes de fin d'année
le moment de la récolte dure quatre à
cinq semaines
traditionnellement les casseurs grimpe
dans les arbres et casse les grappes de
letchis qui se trouve à l'extrémité des
branches rappelle qu'on la branche moi
je la mets de ce projet ici et je le
ramène vers m'en rendre compte que la
bloque
et puis j'ai car seules les branches qui
sont saufs boue ont fait descendre avec
une corde jusqu'en bas et après
quelqu'un là-bas qu'il récupère pour
dévider comme auxerre n'a pas besoin de
descendre on monte chaque fois dans le
purin compte donc on dévie le sac et on
remet bien de sa queue dans les ballots
héros pour le simple occasion une
technique de récoltes non sans danger
les casseurs risque la chute à tout
moment le problème c'est que les arbres
son ratio est comme ça arrive en
décembre déjà wifi y fait chaud on
transpire facilement au niveau des pieds
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à monter les
chaussures et ça glisse donc les
accidents sont dus talus et et le fait
de casser avec un crochet de ramener à
soi donc on est souvent déséquilibrées
aussi les dj se trouve à l'extrémité des
branches les casseurs ne peuvent donc
pas toujours y accéder
ainsi ce sont plusieurs tonnes de fruits
qui se perdent chaque année on a des
letchis qui sont en blouses blanches en
haut où on va pas y arriver donc souvent
c'est ça c'est que il ya énormément de
letchis qui reste sur les pieds à cause
de ça parce que c'est pas accessible
les producteurs souhaitent désormais
trouver une technique de récolte plus
sécurisé mais aussi qui éviterait le
gaspillage
il faut trouver un système qui fait que
on reste en bas et mécanisée bien sûr et
qu'on arrive à accéder aux petits enfin
au bout des bras il faut trouver un
système pour que l'on puisse cueillir
les types qui arrivent au sol avant
d'arriver au sol parce que conserver vos
seuls s'explose la production de lait
qui atteint les 8000 tonnes par an pour
une surface cultivée d'environ 500
hectares
[Musique]